welcome to Table Talk where I unpack
ideas and insights from Christian
theology and spirituality that help you
become a more thoughtful calm and just a
wonderful human being my name's Brett so
fir'd pastor at the table in sexy Texas
and this is part six of our series
titled conflict what to do when
relationships break down and today I
want to talk about the three most common
ways that we bump into ourselves not
literally
it's a metaphor few videos ago I use
this phrase bumping into myself to
describe the way that's so often we're
just very tempted to say the issue is
them it's those people or the issue is
that it's those circumstances I feel
this way I'm acting this way because of
them right what end when the truth is at
the level of the individual right at my
personal level my emotional turmoil
really is mine to deal with and by the
way this is not saying there's no such
thing as injustice in the world or that
if you experience evil it's your fault
not at all this is not about assigning
fault or blame I'm simply talking about
us taking ownership for how we respond
to the actions of others in the
circumstances we find ourselves in so
without further ado let's unpack these
three common ways that we bump into
ourselves
first is the freeze reaction that is to
say I experienced something bad and I
panic and I become paralyzed
so maybe my boss is I'm chewing me out
not just giving me feedback but it's a
verbal lashing and instead of saying you
know there's maybe some truth in what
you're saying but you need to calm down
right this is an appropriate instead I
just freeze you ever been there
like your mind is just blank no words
are coming we all listen feel totally
incapable of action so this reaction
really goes all the way back to our
brain and what we might call it's sort
of popularly known as the the reptile or
the lizard
brain it's sort of the the right there
on our brainstem this portion of our
brain is basically it's responsible for
keeping us alive and what can happen is
that when we become overwhelmed by fear
boom we freeze right just like the deer
caught in the headlights or a rabbit
hiding from the wolf we freeze so that's
the first way that we bump into
ourselves it's sort of the freeze
reaction second is the flight reaction
this is where I become afraid or hurt or
emotionally wounded and I run like
perhaps literally I actually get up and
run out of the room or more you know
metaphorically my mind starts racing and
I'm no longer tracking what the other
person is saying or doing because I am
planning my exit my brain is screaming
go go go go go go
if you ever find yourself basically
constantly ending friendships or
quitting jobs and not just you know one
but it's like this is a pattern
threatening divorce all the time it's
very likely this is your brains learned
response right that's how you're
protecting yourself it's it's the flight
reaction third way that we bump into
ourselves is of course the fight
reaction this is the person who when
backed into the metaphorical corner
comes out swinging and this could be
like literal physical violence more
often it's with words alright so they
feel attacked verbally and what do they
do they go on the attack their life
motto is the best defense is a good
offense and I honestly I see this on
myself a lot when someone for example
critiques or criticizes me there it
comes out just the other day my wife
Maggie was very kindly honestly she was
pointing out that the way I was
parenting our children was less than
helpful and so she's giving me this
feedback it immediately my brain begins
to just race and create excuses
and construct elaborate arguments and
then counter arguments to what I know
will be her arguments against my
arguments and in that moment it was i
interested in learning about myself was
i attempting to become a better parent
no I was ready to fight my way out of
that situation to preserve my fragile
sense of self so that was me bumming in
myself right and those are the three
common ways that we find ourselves doing
this throughout our days our weeks are
years right is we're bumping to
ourselves through by we by freezing
there are flight through our fight okay
so what's the answer how do we overcome
this honestly there is no answer there's
no hope I'm kidding all right so there's
a pretty simple three-step formula I got
this from therapists and a professor of
mine dr. Frank Greene I mentioned him
few videos back and so he has a three
sort of step process step one is he
calls it sort of stop
step two back up step three
do it again so stop back up do it again
you see the brain this really comes back
to some things we've learned about
neuroscience and basically the brain
forms really deep grooves along the
three reactions the freeze the the
flight the fight reactions and so the
when you do this over and over and over
it's like it's sort of like a groove you
can think of it like a path in the
forest that over time through use it
eventually becomes you know a wide road
and then after decades of a certain
reaction and now it's like an eight-lane
superhighway and so by so these three
steps are basically helping you cut a
new path so when you stop right you're
refusing to go down that superhighway
when you back up you're saying you know
that wasn't such a good response let me
try a different path let me begin to
forge a new way
responding and then dude again is
walking out a new response and so
perhaps instead of the freeze reaction
that superhighway you choose to respond
calmly and you stand up for yourself
right that's a new path or stopping
you're backing up and you're doing
something different or instead of the
flight reaction you respond by facing
the fear addressing it instead of the
fight response reaction you you respond
with that a few deep breaths and just a
more vulnerable and honest you know
there might be truth in what you're
saying right so I believe this point is
captured really beautifully by a life
coach friend of mine her name is Wendy
good and she set it up like this she
said we must learn to respond not react
and I think that's exactly it so that's
the three steps stop back up dude again
and over time you'll begin to form new
healthier superhighways
which will positively impact honestly
your response in every conflict you find
yourself in and that's a really big deal
so that's all for today if you enjoyed
this video please like it comment share
it with a friend and subscribe to my
youtube channel by searching Brett
Tilford grace and peace